I get asked so often about my interest
in photography where did it come from
why do I do it well let me explain when
I was graduating high school I told my
stepfather I really want to become a
photographer because I just learned how
to develop film and I was getting into
image making and he said that's great
but how are you gonna make a living I
said well I'll be a photographer and
I'll make a living being a photographer
he said maybe you should go to college
and get a couple of years under your
belt and then if you still love it that
much you can pursue it so I had a lot of
respect for him I took his advice off to
college I went I got degrees in
environmental studies and psychology and
professional shuffleboarding which is
basically what I did with my four years
there I was a party house I'm just
telling you the truth when I finished
that I said dad I think I want to become
a photographer he said you're gonna
starve to death
son what you've done is basically party
through college pay you basically wasted
four years I said what about these
degrees I have you said yeah great go
get a job now I don't want to be
critical of the arts obviously but he
was right he suggested at that point was
look why don't you go get a business
degree and learn the basics of business
that if you really want to be a
photographer after that at least you
know how to build a business around it
again it was pretty good advice I went
and got a business degree in MBA that
was quite an eye-opener first of all was
really hard but at the same time I
realized how tough business can be and
it really kind of triggered my
entrepreneurial spirit because in those
times that I had learned that being an
employee wasn't really good for me and
while I was in the MBA course I said to
my professors why don't you let me
document this as a filmmaker I'll shoot
the two years I'm going to spend here
and you'll have an archival piece that
you can show future generations of
students what it's like to go through
the MBA program help me fund it I'll
shoot it I'll edit it I'll produce it
that's what I did and it was a really
interesting journey for me I became a
camera man not just with stills but a
shot Arriflex 16mm film I
learned how to operate an 8 plate
steamed back editor which a lot of
people that came out of the film
industry they know what that is today
it's done all digitally and I've kept my
editing chops by the way I still edit
every weekend just to keep that feel of
what it's like because it's a great
talent I think to maintain and I found
out it was a pretty good editor and a
pretty good cameraman I soaked the film
to my dad and he said well what's the
business about this but what happened
was that the film was really well
received I'll show you a couple of
seconds of it just for the fun of it
it's tough anything worthwhile it's
tough I think that if it wasn't tough
our students and our alumni wouldn't be
very happy because it would have been a
wasted couple of years it's tough I
think that we do this deliberately when
students arrive here on their first day
in class the first part of September
they can't believe the work that we're
serious about the workload that we
provide they can't believe the number of
assignments the amount of reading the
amount of time the amount of study group
work the the intensity of the classes
day after day it's really tough and it
produces pretty high stress levels we've
got some motion that says what doesn't
kill you makes you strong I'm really
looking forward to it
I know it's a lot of hard work and you
hear a lot of stories about the hours
that are put in just how rigorous it is
but I figure I can handle the challenge
well how do I feel that's a good
question
it's um back in back in the mid autumn
you're doing an awful lot of work and
the objective of what you're trying to
do isn't always entirely clear the the
big thing that you acquire is the year
progresses is the ability to determine
what the key issues are and what's
extraneous to the the problem
[Music]
okay let's continue down the road
[Music]
that's me in the mid-80s getting back in
my old BMW 2002 a candy red car I just
loved anyways the film was a huge hit
and basically I started getting calls
from companies saying you're gonna keep
this up or you're gonna keep doing this
kind of corporate documentary stuff I
said why and they said look there's a
lot of interest in this kind of thing
and we formed a company called special
event television it ended up being a
production platform for the network's
in sports television primarily around
hockey shows like Bobby Orr and the
hockey legend the original six and one
that became a monster hit Don Cherry's
grapevine we owned the format so if you
lived in one of the original six cities
like Boston and Detroit these became
immensely popular Saturday programming
etc so what happened is we sold the
company when we were approached it was
my first deal that we started from zero
and we sold it I took the proceeds of
that and started what became the
Learning Company and on and on and on to
where I am today but I never forgot my
love of photography now I've been very
fortunate in my business travels I've
been almost everywhere always taking
that camera with me sometimes the film
camera sometimes it's digital but I
always have one with me not just my cell
phone because you need to be able to
sculpt images with a lens you want to
have wide angles with you and telephotos
it's not easy to do that with a digital
camera and I'm not against them I do
have images from my digital cameras but
the images you're going to see here are
taken primarily with all kinds of
different professional cameras I have a
lot of them now I've kind of gone back
to where I was when I was graduating
high school except now I can afford the
best equipment it's been a really
interesting journey and I've said to my
dad look I want to get back into
photography and he's been looking at
these images to saying this is what
you're destined to do not to try and
make a life out of it you pursued
business that's great now you can afford
cameras go ahead and shoot your heart's
content which I do and I sell these
images and give the profits to young
entrepreneurs I think it's wonderful
but let me take you on the journey let's
first look at what a show looks like and
then I'll get into the specific prints
here we go Kevin's been an amateur
shutterbug since the 70s now he's
selling his prints and giving the
proceeds to help young entrepreneurs
earlier today he walked me through his
exhibit 40 years of photography so
here's the inside scoop on some of his
prints
well back in 1980 I had a career as an
editor on a steam back my work was in a
darkroom cutting film for the Olympics I
was always interested in pursuing a
career as a photographer so I always had
a camera with me I've taken thousands of
images over the years where ever I've
traveled TV is a career and my business
career is taking me everywhere and this
is a collection of my 40-year journey
and images from all these different
places I've been to it's very difficult
to curate a show like this but when we
took that theme all of a sudden it came
together so there's 40 years of
photography here and obviously that's
gonna be a whole range of not just your
experiences but also different types of
cameras what's the kind of first camera
you had well the first camera I could
afford was a Soviet made Zenit II it was
very inexpensive it had limitations in
fact I have a photograph of it here in
the exhibit and it was the first time I
ever had an SLR which you shoot through
the lands a 35 millimeter and I took my
very first images of that as I could
afford it I always upgraded my my you
know photography equipment today I have
many many different cameras I shoot with
Hasselblad's Leica's all kinds of
different technology but it's remarkable
in this show some of my in other
people's view my best work comes from my
earliest lowest-cost cameras which shows
you photography is an eclectic art you
just don't know when you're capturing an
image how great we will be as time
passed do you have a favorite out of
these images here obviously this is
distilling down a lot of your work of
the ones you've chosen to show here or
there's something that really jump out
for you there is one that I took decades
ago in an Armenian Church using the
light of candles it's right over here
and what I like about this image is it's
been reborn in a different way using
technology these candles provided very
very limited life and this was not
digital at the time this was taken with
Triax black-and-white film and because
of its limitations there's two
characters in here a face
on the far left and one on the right
which is very haunting that I could
never pull from the negative decades ago
using today's digital technology re
scanning the images and working with
some great technicians there's almost 20
people involved in this show we were
able to find that person existing in the
civil nitro he was there before we we
could be we knew he was there but we
couldn't pull him we couldn't pull him
out and and we were able to do it using
this remarkable new technology and and I
think now this image is completely
different than what I envisioned if I
showed you the original one can versus
this this face is very haunting and
actually the most interesting part of it
it's the kind of tension in the image is
his face exactly so which is why I find
this work so interesting because it's a
combination of what happened that moment
decades ago and technology that allowed
it to be reborn you have I mean we look
at kind of the range of stuff you've got
here when you're out you're wandering
and this is obviously kind of a conic
piece this piece the curator who hung
this Peter Hill this is his favorite
piece because he's of this generation
this bust was stolen after he died you
cannot find it anymore it's a very rare
piece and it's a it captures that moment
when Morrison's bust which is somewhere
on this earth but nobody knows where
it's been stolen these are very recent
these were taken this year in st. Barths
I call this woman on chains I love the
soft woman on these hard chains and this
is just a whimsical picture that
happened this summer on Nantucket the
lifeguard actually was taking a bite out
of a sandwich I didn't photoshop his
head out of it and the more you look at
it the more it raises questions all
kinds of naughty questions oh you have
to go there I have to because people
have told me about this image now and
I've had lots of emails about it saying
it's one of their favorite and the
exhibit did you take it knowing that he
was gonna bend over and take the bite
out of this and I started to see it
happen when because he was eating the
sandwich repeatedly and I thought this
is interesting
yeah his head's gone and and I I only
had that one frame that I was able to
get it but it was it and I just loved
the technology now this is a metallic
paper called flex you can almost touch
that wood yes technology in photography
now is so remarkable
these are our Chi ville Museum prints
they're very expensive to make but I'm
going to be selling them at this exhibit
and what are you doing with the money
when why are you doing this
I want to support an initiative to
support teenage entrepreneurs so that's
what we're promoting here and I'm going
to take this exhibit across North
America staying on that theme all right
let me show you my favorite one please
do this one this one this has a very
interpreted provenance here's what
happened it was one of my first digital
images and I lost the original digital
file
I had one paper image left of it wery
scanned it and now it's this thank you
very much Amanda you know that old
classic line every picture tells a story
well of course it's true how about the
one behind me I took this picture from
2,000 feet in a giant Sikorsky
helicopter over Greenland working on a
show for Discovery Channel called
project earth now I'm gonna do something
really crazy here watch this dissolve
now let's get into the image what
happens in July in August on the surface
of Greenland is rather incredible it is
a complete desolate ice desert you don't
even see any life there at all but when
a dark piece of metal like a meteorite
falls out of the sky and hits that white
snow it immediately becomes a heat sink
in other words the Sun setting it it's
heating up the ice which melts to water
water is blue and it's darker than the
ice and it absorbs more Sun so it starts
to heat up and within hours these giant
rivers are formed and they become the
size of the Grand Canyon and then an
entire glacial lake builds up it gets so
heavy in a matter of just a few hours
that sometimes and if you watch them
satellites it becomes a size of a 2 or 3
mile lake and then BOOM it's so heavy it
cracks the ice it fissures it and the
water plunges down in a matter of
seconds to where the ice hits the rock
now this is why you have to care about
these Lakes these giant lakes forming
because the more than the form the more
of them that cab that's the process of
breaking and having water flush to the
bottom the more the ice moves
off and the glaciers basically are
lubricated by this surface of water
between themselves in the rock and they
plunge into the oceans and so that's
what we were doing and the show is
starting to investigate I was actually
asked to go to one of the boats so they
could fill me on the water the problem
with that is I was getting hip to the
idea that wait a second if this thing
cabs the entire thing will flush like a
toilet in a few seconds and this water
will plunge down the fissure along with
me and I'll be found in 10,000 years
frozen like a woolly mammoth
so I said the cameraman I'm not doing
that buddy so they wrapped up the
soundman to look like me and off he went
in that boat believe me he was scared he
was shaking in his boots and they were
only out there for a few minutes to get
that shot but a few days later that Lake
disappeared had we been on that they
would have disappeared too that's the
crazy stuff documentary filmmakers like
to do but you got to be hip to what
they're thinking
I love making TV but I'm not risking my
life for it at least I want to reduce
the risk what a phenomenal shoot that
was we were in 38 different countries in
11 months so basically I took a lot of
images here's more of them
[Music]
you know I've always believed if you
want to be successful in business you
have to have the discipline of what
business is all about it's very binary
either you make or you lose money it's
very black and white but to be
successful in it you need the chaos of
art you want to combine the two things
together find your artistic side the yin
and the yang the left on the right side
of the brain find whatever that is for
you is it music is it photography is it
painting whatever it is you've got to
explore that while you're focusing on
growing a business or being an
entrepreneur they fit together the
better you are at blending them the more
successful you'll be I hope you really
enjoyed this little journey into
photography with me I've been doing it
for a very long time it really helps it
helps you think about what life is all
about
I love making money you know that but I
love the arts too blending that's what
it's all about
yin and yang until next time wonderful
on photography take care of my friends